we refused to sweep things under the rug
that is not Who We Are
and it's not what we stand for so we
just want you to know that we had no
idea this was going on the try guys
break their silence following Ned
Fulmer's dramatic exit we've come such a
long way I don't know that we'll ever be
able to fully articulate the pain we
feel at this moment you
'd we're losing a friend we're losing
someone we built a company with we have
countless memories with we're obviously
incredibly shocked and deeply hurt by
all of this this is someone who we built
a brand and a company with for eight
years now we have our own production
company we have a staff of 15 people
they explain Ned's consensual workplace
relationship was a complete surprise and
it kicked off an investigation which led
to his house staying on Labor Day
weekend multiple fans alerted us that
they had seen Ned and an employee
engaging in public romantic Behavior we
reached out to check on that employee
Ned confirmed the reports and since
confirmed that this had been going on
for some time and thus began a
three-week process of engaging with
employment lawyers corporate lawyers HR
PR and more the three of us signed
written consent of the members of second
try LLC approving the removal of Ned as
a manager and an employee while he's no
longer a try guy Ned's still featured in
some upcoming posts but the former
members getting removed from many videos
and at a great expense there are several
videos that we've deemed as fully
unreleasable you will never see them and
that is due to his involvement and
that's a decision that has cost us lots
of money now there are videos that were
shot ahead of all this right we're going
to be editing net out like the new
season of without a recipe and we're
working with our editors and finding
Creative Solutions to the footage the
group also shares a sensitive request to
the fans and while we consider this a
company matter I'm there's just also a
family at the center of this and we ask
that you respect the privacy of the
family members and employees who may be
caught up in this
we also want to remind you that the
internet has a tendency to be a lot
harsher towards women than men so please
we ask that you exercise kindness for
Ned's part he offered an apology
following the shocking Revelation taking
to social media and writing family
should have always been my priority but
I lost Focus I'm sorry for any pain that
my actions may have caused just right
now we're focused on bringing the best
content possible between now and the end
of the year and then figuring out what
the future of this channel looks like
from there but it's going to be hard
it's this whole thing is going to be
really [ __ ] hard
foreign